encuentre la probabilidad de sacar una
canica amarilla de una bolsa que tiene
tres canicas amarillas dos verdes dos
rojas y una azul vamos a dibujarlas nos
dicen entonces que en la bolsa hay tres
canicas amarillas aquí están una dos
tres nos dicen que hay dos canicas
verdes las dibujamos suponiendo que
están revueltas en la bolsa hay dos
canicas rojas
las dibujamos aquí y finalmente hay una
canica Azul Por acá y quieren saber la
probabilidad para sacar una canica
amarilla Así que quieren conocer la
probabilidad de sacar una
canica
amarilla la probabilidad es una forma de
expresar de que salga algo que nosotros
queremos compar con la probabilidad de
que salgan todas las demás opciones otra
forma de pensar en ello es el número de
posibles resultados de que salga lo que
queremos en este caso la canica amarilla
Comparado contra el total de todas las
opciones posibles que pueden salir de
aquí si yo voy a seleccionar una canica
Cuántos eventos puedo tener al hacerlo
Cuántas canicas amarillas hay aquí que
yo puedo elegir Pues hay tres Así que
aquí tenemos tres canicas amarillas que
podemos elegir una dos 3es y suponemos
que aquí todas tienen la misma
probabilidad de ser elegidas así que
tenemos tres canicas amarillas que
podemos elegir de un total de Cuántas
canicas hay en la bolsa bueno Esto es
entre el número total de canicas que
existen 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 ocho canicas que
hay en la bolsa Así que la probabilidad
de seleccionar una canica amarilla es de
3oc hay una probabilidad de tres a ocho
de elegir una canica amarilla de esta
bolsa y de nuevo Les comento Este es el
número de probabilidades de lo que
queremos o de lo que nos interesa que
ocurra entre el número de probabilidades
totales de lo que puede suceder en este
caso tenemos ocho eventos posibles en
esta situación puedo sacar ocho canicas
porque son ocho canicas las que tengo
son ocho cosas diferentes que puedo
sacar de la bolsa tres de ellas
coinciden con lo que me interesa que
sean canicas amarillas es decir tres de
estas satisfacen mi condición que es que
sean canicas
amarillas